a little Zen being a dad there we go
let's talk about that yeah yeah how did
I forget oh my god dude you gonna feed
that baby hot cheeto milk looking hot
cheeto milk broke his girlfriend just
eating so much hot cheetos that she's
like little xan's life just seemed so
[ __ ] messy and weird yeah it like
messy in the sense that like his life is
like a sixteen year old boy's room like
it's not actual drama it's just like
mess he's creating for himself hundred
percent like what the [ __ ] was that [ __ ]
where he was getting pissed off at the
fire department see that [ __ ] you know
like a fourteen snap tirade about the
fire department it sounds like he called
them because there was a fire and they
laughed at him how much hot cheetos were
too hot yeah right now you guys gotta
get here he's like yo [ __ ] the [ __ ]
LA County number y'all are some [ __ ]
like I black face cussing at the [ __ ]
fire department he's like y'all like I
told y'all we had an emergency y'all
just laughed at me I'm like I guarantee
you did not deliver it to them in a
clear and concise way I'm sure you
called them saying all kinds of madness
and they're like what like yo what's up
what's good by the way yeah [ __ ] I
got what was the emergency even I want
to look it up but yeah he was dogging
him out I was dying man yeah may have
[ __ ] the fire department [ __ ] the fire
department
yeah little yeah lil zan filing lawsuit
against Los Angeles Fire Department he's
suing them this would man come on bro
let's see what this shit's all about
dude oh well they call 9-1-1 when his
girlfriend started to experience
problems with his
wrote what when help arrived he was
totally disrespected okay all right here
we go let's see what the audio has to
say this is him ranting now bro her face
is fair how much weed did you smoke are
you I'm sorry man them roasting someone
on the way to the hospital is so cold
and so funny how high are you right how
much [ __ ] we did you smoke your
pothead
what's up with your throat man got too
many Oreos in there [ __ ] is Guinea neck
ass you think it was from Hot Cheetos
yeah yeah it like throat sores from all
the [ __ ] cheeto dust yeah I bet your
kid's gonna be born with with orange
cheeto fingers yeah well I better that's
the party's leaving out but he kept
making fun of her throat dude why they
just kept making fun of you guys [ __ ]
up you have why are they making fun of
her throat don't worry about it dude
don't worry about I mean it's weird for
someone just to make fun of someone's
throat that's your thing to make photo
what was going on
we have two bags of hot cheetos all
right but that's besides the point okay
here we are this alright Oh throw it on
fire they were like family style bags
whoa Chester going for the gold over
here chill out man Chester cheeto in
this [ __ ] if he names his kid
Chester Chester V that would just be the
full circle right there it's funny
because like the [ __ ] just doesn't
happen
what like the [ __ ] that finds him you
know oh yeah
[ __ ] that happens with the meme and like
dating Miley Cyrus's sister and I like
you know yeah it's just like you know
he's like the victim in all these
scenarios right but it's like I don't
know this [ __ ] doesn't happen other
people ya know you know yeah a certain
extent it's like why like why are you
tattooing [ __ ] black liquid on your
eye if you don't want if you don't want
IMT people to roast you yeah yeah I mean
is that fair to say I guess in my mind I
don't think EMTs should be held to a
certain standard because I'm going out
on a limb here okay because they don't
make [ __ ] my boy was EMT for like three
years huh give me like $14 an hour and
destroyed his back Jesus lifting bodies
all day just people pass the plate don't
make [ __ ] it's a tough job too man
yeah people's lives are in your hand
yeah so if you if he [ __ ] pulls up
and you're like do my [ __ ] girl like
she oh [ __ ] dude like she has hot
cheetos and like her throat is [ __ ] up
it's not beyond them to be like did you
[ __ ] what are you on man what are you on
dawg why did you call the fire
department
they're our throat people dying right
now that I could be saving and I'm here
that's probably their I'm here with your
[ __ ] high stupid ass and you wanted
to be taken to the hospital for throat
problems are you that's also a weird
thing like if your throat isn't like
closing like what was it like actively
closing yeah what does a throat problem
and besides that that's the only problem
with your throat other problems you just
go to the doctor what other problems are
there yeah I don't know whose throat
just [ __ ] bus
to open all of a sudden I have no idea
would have allowed her throat ah
dude she's giving that good neck and eye
blood hearth rug good crazy
not if she ate too many hot cheetos a
broke her throat down flex